good morning Chris what's happening dad
uh what did you think of my Jake Crowder
Gordon Hayward comment uh I can see your
argument there I i think for Boston
though Gordon Hayward is probably a
better player if you look at what the
self is lack they've got point guard
scoring they've got power forward
scoring now they don't have a wing score
they've got some very good defenders but
they don't have a perimeter scorer so I
agree that the difference is not that
significant between Crowder and Haywood
but for the Celtics Haywood might be a
better player moreover dan it's a little
what much ado about nothing here I mean
the sub expands cheered him for like
three seconds at opening introduction
not like they were cheering every time
we touch the ball in that game deal a
nice a little bit of overreaction I
think by Jake Roberts alright so here we
go here's here's our pronunciation game
with the Greek freak Milwaukee star
player who hit the game-winner i'm going
to play all five here and i want you to
tell us which one number one two three
four five is the closest to the actual
pronunciation of the Greek freak alright
Satan alright well we'll start with Paul
paps the creator of say this name
correct ok ready g honest I to the combo
Janice I see the combo ok save your
answer Chris all right we'll move on to
Andrew mclovin pearl off Gianna's aunt
at econo lodge Gianna's on tactical who
I'm poopa that's close it's a very close
some pines yeah oompah oompah all right
next one Todd Fritz g honest ante tu
cumple ok G honest ante tu cumple I'll
play mine next yiannis Huntington compo
yiannis Huntington come I think you got
the first name right yeah yiannis son
team can come all right now I play mine
let mannix decide gianna sunta took comp
ball Jeon assunta took combo Mannix okay
well first those were all pretty
terrible um Seaton sounded like he was
saying kung pao chicken and yet
uh pearl off didn't even try and I
didn't know what Paulie was saying there
uh Dan I'd say your closest um you don't
say the G yeah at the beginning of it so
most of you guys got it wrong there it's
really I mean it's crazy the name is it
is it's it's not that hard to say it's
phonetically pronounced the intent to
come PO I mean that's so you read it and
you say it like that attend to kupo
attend to coop oh yes had he say his
first name yanis yiannis attenti gone
it'll be honest attempt the comp oh yeah
Paulie in the he is originally his
family's from Nigeria and I think
phonetically the p.o is pronounced bo so
the end of the name should be Kumba not
compol are you basing that on anything
in reality or are you just saying that I
yes that's is a combo well I checked I
pronuncia it was bo2 I thought it was
authentic gumbo I think I'm annex no I
look I'd have to double check but I've
been named a couple of years now like
this item I had this conversation with
him because he was telling me that his
first year in the league every PA
announcer in the NBA got his name wrong
every single water even his home town
announcer for a while was getting his
name wrong so I'm pretty sure it's poke
okay I thought it was Bo and it's uh I'm
also if he's yiannis but but he's he's
not from he wasn't born in Greece right
no it was not okay would you pronounce
Gianna's differently where he's from as
opposed to in Greek grease right up
possibly okay so sorta took oh I think
it might be G honest hunted the gumbo
because all I can tell you is how he
pronounced it to me as that's the only
thing I can guess Polly he could be
saying it wrong his whole life he's only
ten oh wow okay poor kid saying it wrong
honest I'm tetek on you little poop I
terrible mclovin almost got that right
it's like you gave up mid last name
berloff i can barely say your name Chris
I'd terrible day okay we're honest I
takano who I'm poopa when when does he
start to get on the national stage where
we put him up there with Anthony Davis
and some of these other kids who were 22
23 years of age you don't think he's
already there I say nationally Hey yeah
i mean he's not there nationally no but
i think he's an all-star this year and
that will will vault him off to that
stage I mean I watched him in New York
last night and forget the last shot but
i think this is it's crazy it's sort of
hyperbolic but there's almost nothing he
can't do I mean the fact that he can
ball handle the way that he can shoot
the way that he can and plays with this
this confidence that he does I mean he
is going to be next year you know I
think a bona fide superstar in this
league all-star this year national stage
by februari next year right up there
Anthony Davis level the other thing I
wanted to bring up is how many how many
different 50-point games have we had
individual like different players five
this year yeah five or six why I'm like
that to me brother recently feels like
it's a is it a little easier and if so
why why are we seeing more players
getting 50 I don't know if it's if it's
any easier I think it to look at at each
player and and their responsibilities
with the team James Harden is everything
to Houston Russell Westbrook is
everything toe coma city in you know
they'll win Chicago usually unless Jimmy
Butler kind of goes off but there
haven't been any rule changes or
anything like that damn has been nothing
that suggests that it's easier
offensively for players I just think the
guys are scoring 50 plus are like
including Isiah Thomas who is you know
the engine for Boston are the guys that
are required to carry the team's for
them to win how hard is it going to be
two separate what Westbrook is doing and
harden is doing if you know you we're
looking at guys who aren't going to be
playing for a championship more than
likely by up it's it's rare when
somebody gets the MVP and they're not
playing for a title contender yeah it's
I mean I don't know what the numbers are
specifically but it's more often than
not a top one or two team in their
conference is the guy that get the MVP I
think harden has the best chance here to
break the mold now
Russell Westbrook average the
triple-double that that might shake up
the edge sketch completely but Houston
is one of the biggest surprises of this
year I mean they are where they second
or third or fourth in the Western
Conference right now and nobody expected
that and hardens bendy reason for that
so if Houston finishes third or fourth
and hard and keeps up this pace I think
he's going to get it over the likes of
durant and lebron and some of the teams
in those top two chris thanks for
joining us for the probably one time
only that will have the Greek freak
pronunciation good but we appreciate
that my pleasure damn alright that's
Chris Mannix the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]